- IT'S ME AND MY DAUGHTER,
NICOLE.
I GUESS THIS WILL BE
"BATTLE PART 2,"
'CAUSE MOST OF YOU FOLKS
SAY THAT SHE WON.
BUT THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S GOOD.
HERE WE GO.
[PERCUSSIVE BEATBOXING]
♪ ♪
- OTAY.
[BEATBOXING RAPIDLY]
♪ ♪
CAPTURE THAT.
[BEATBOXING DRAMATICALLY]
♪ ♪
FINISH ON THAT.
HA.
- IF YOU WERE TO TELL ME
THAT ALEX SMITH
WOULD ONE DAY
HAVE A BLACK FAN...
HO-HO-HO.
THERE ARE A LOT WORSE WAYS
A DAUGHTER COULD USE HER MOUTH
ON THE INTERNET.
AS A PARENT,
THE GREATEST JOY IN LIFE
IS WATCHING YOUR CHILDREN EXCEL.
AND SINCE BEATBOXING
IS THE ONE ACTIVITY
THAT BRINGS
ALL FAMILIES TOGETHER...
I'M HERE WITH MY FIRSTBORN
DAUGHTER, SUMMER.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE BEATBOX BATTLE.
I'LL GO FIRST.
[BEATBOXING]
♪ ♪
- [BLEEP] OFF, DAD!
- SHE'S GOING THROUGH
A BIT OF A PHASE RIGHT NOW.
LEAVE THE KNIVES
IN THE KITCHEN, PLEASE!
I ADOPTED THIS LITTLE INDIGENOUS
ANGEL "DOWN UNDAH."
[SPITTING]
[CLICKING TONGUE]
HOOHM.
[BEATBOXING]
♪ ♪
MM.
[DIDGERIDOO PLAYING]
♪ ♪
STILL PAINT HER UP
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
STRIP HER OF HER HERITAGE.
AND FINALLY,
THE PRIDE OF THE TOSH CLAN,
MY HANDSOME
IDENTICAL TRIPLETS.
THIS IS DAVE, DONNIE,
AND DANNY JUNE.
ALWAYS TRY TO KEEP THEM
IN THAT SAME ORDER.
ALL RIGHT.
[PUCKERING LIPS
AND SPITTING]
- [BEATBOXING]
♪ ♪
- ♪ DOO-DOO-DOO ♪
♪ DOO-DOO-DOO ♪
♪ OOH ♪
♪ WHOA ♪
♪ DOO-DOO-DOO ♪
♪ AH, OH ♪
- ♪ WHOA ♪
♪ YOU'RE THE ONE
THAT I LOVE ♪
♪ AND YOU'RE RUNNING
AWAY FROM ME ♪
♪ OH, YEAH ♪
- ♪ YOU'RE THE ONE ♪
- THANKS FOR SHOWING
ME UP, GUYS!
WHY DON'T YOU GO LIVE
WITH YOUR WHORE MOTHER?
I AM CURRENTLY IN A NASTY
CUSTODY BATTLE WITH MY EX-WIFE,
AND NEITHER OF US EVER REALLY
TOOK TO THAT AUSSIE KID.